zusammen und herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live mit ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen fragenden
kommentare zu unserem thema sehr gerne
posten unten rein ich gucke was wir
davon mit in den livestream nehmen
können
und wenn sie oder ihr jetzt in der zdf-
heute- app schaut oder online
dann gibt es da auch eine möglichkeit
sich zu beteiligen nämlich in einer mail
am zdf heute - live at zdf.de zdf
heute.de zdf.de das wird mir dann hier
durchgereicht einem normalen in einem
normalen jahr wäre eigentlich heute
abend ein festtag für jeden fußballfan
die erste runde dfb-pokal startet
nämlich jetzt zu dem viertel von einer
guten stunde dann ist die sommerpause im
fußball endlich vorbei man kann mit
seinen ganzen freunden und mit seinen
ganzen fußball fans wieder zusammen ins
stadion mal ein paar stunden einfach
alles von sich lassen sich gehen lassen
sein team anfeuern und sich drei bis
zwölf bier rein stellen eigentlich aber
dieses jahr ist ja alles anders ist es
2020 und wir haben corona und die
eigentlich mal zuschauerstärkste
fußball-liga der welt hat so gut wie
überhaupt keine zuschauer mehr das waren
eigentlich mal 18,8 millionen menschen
die die spiele der bundesliga und der
zweiten bundesliga in einer saison
gesehen haben aber seit märz geht gar
nichts mehr da wurde erstmal der
spielbetrieb komplett eingestellt dann
gab es ab mitte mai die geisterspiele
zumindest ein bisschen fußball kommt man
wieder gucken und seitdem die
infektionszahlen sinken wird aber wieder
heftig diskutiert unter welchen
voraussetzungen vielleicht es doch
wieder zuschauer ins stadion kommen
könnten
der die dfl hat anfang august ein
hygiene konzept vorgelegt das wurde aber
besonders aus der bundespolitik nicht so
richtig gerne gesehen da gab es diesen
tweet hier vom gesundheitsminister am 10
august tausende zuschauer in den stadien
das passt nicht zum aktuellen
infektionsgeschehen jetzt heißt es keine
vermeidbaren risiken eingehen das
konzept der dfl ist in der theorie gut
entscheidend ist in der pandemie aber
die praxis im alltag so tatsächlich aber
geht heute der spielbetrieb wieder los
mit dem dfb-pokal erste runde und es
gibt tatsächlich die ersten spiele mit
zuschauern zum beispiel in mainz tritt
der fsv mainz 05 gegen tsv havelse an
die gesagt viertel vor acht ist am fuß
und jammer die ersten bilder mal vom
stadion
wie das aussieht und wird man sagen
normaler fußballbetrieb sieht anders aus
das sieht doch alles sehr langsam
gesittet und den viel abstand
da muss man sich registrieren und so ein
richtiger fußball abend ist glaube ich
für die meisten fans dann doch was
anderes
das sieht eher nach dem besuch in europa
aus zumindest vom abstand her
am stadion steht meine kollegin nina
niebergall
da bin ich mal gespannt ob die leitung
steht da ist sie hallo nina
normalerweise wäre das der knackevoll
hinter dir aber 1000 leute dürfen jetzt
freien
wir haben gerade ja gehört der
bundesumweltminister wollte eigentlich
niemand im stadion haben warum dann
jetzt doch warum geht alles was ja da
spielen tatsächlich mehrere faktoren
rolle also zum einen ist es so dass
großveranstaltungen ohne hygiene konzept
und ohne kontakt nachverfolgung
tatsächlich bis ende des jahres verboten
sind die vereine die jetzt aber wie hier
in mainz fans in die stadien lassen wir
haben ja ein hütchen konzepten die
können auch die kontakt nachverfolgung
gewährleisten
das ist das eine der zweite punkt ist
dass die ausgestaltung der korona
maßnahmen die liegt bei den ländern
das heißt die einzelnen bundesländer
können entscheiden ob sie prinzipiell
fans wieder in die stadien lassen und
auch ungefähr die größenordnung davon
der dritte punkt ist dann noch dass die
vereine im einzelnen auch eigene hygiene
konzepte vorlegen müssen und die in
absprache mit den gesundheitsämtern dann
absegnen lassen müssen
und genau das hat er mainz 05 gemacht
wie sieht denn das konzept aus von mainz
05 ist das irgendwie was das besonders
überraschend ist
neda ist jetzt nichts besonders
überraschend ist dabei das sind
eigentlich die klassiker abstand
natürlich maske tragen überall auf dem
gelände
außer wenn die leute dann am sitzplatz
sitzen stehplätze gibt es überhaupt
nicht essen und trinken nur zum
mitnehmen und alkohol wird auch nicht
ausgeschenkt also im prinzip die
klassiker mit dem zusatz noch dass es
hier eben auch keinen alkohol gibt und
ich habe jetzt hier auch einen fan bei
mir das ist der kevin schön mit abstand
an dich wäre jetzt noch die frage wieso
kommst du unter solchen bedingungen
heute ins stadion
das war jetzt lange zeit ohne fußball
und ich gehe einfach davon aus wenn
jetzt wieder fenster eingelassen werden
dass das eben auch sicher ist und als
dauerkarteninhaber habe bin ich auf
jeden fall gespannt gewesen was mich
jetzt halt einfach erwartet
wir haben eine chance aber auch
vielleicht entspannter eigen ja dann
meine frage an kevin wer jetzt für mich
alles andere nach fußball aus gerade
wenn ich ehrlich sein soll wie viel
findet das jetzt ja wenn unser moderator
daniel der hat jetzt gefragt das ist
jetzt nicht der fußball den wir kennen
vor allem nicht der stadion fußball den
wir kennen also keine fangesänge wenig
leute im stadion
man kann nicht zusammen feiern zusammen
fangesänge grün wie findest du das denn
ja so ist das ist halt auch nicht der
fußball den wir irgendwie wollen aber es
ist ein anfang auf jeden fall
und ich glaube mit zum anfangen kann man
halt auch erstmal leben also das ist
irgendwie nach und nach irgendwie
gesteigert wird
dass man das halt auch überprüfen kann
ob das sinn hat ob die gene konzepte
passen und ich glaube jeder würde gerne
wieder die alten regelungen oder so wie
es früher war aber das geht halt einfach
aufgrund der pandemie nicht und dann
lebe ich halt auch erstmal damit bis das
stück für stück weiter gemacht wird und
du hast dich dann aber auch dafür
entschieden nicht die entspanntere
bequemere variante zu hause auf der
couch zu wählen obwohl du da vielleicht
sogar mit deinen kumpels hätte setzen
können
im bier trinken können wieso hast du das
hier nicht ein bisschen entspannter
gemacht sage ich mal
ja aber also auch wenn das heute nicht
das stadion erlebnis sein wird aber man
hat dann doch irgendwie wieder lust
gehabt mal wieder ins stadion
es hat ja auch so unter flutlicht das
hat auch was seinen besonderen reiz
irgendwie und ja irgendwie war dann doch
die lust größer und dass man jetzt
einfach wieder ansteigen geht sich auch
das hygiene konzept mal anguckt und ich
glaube halt nur wenn leute das ihm auch
annehmen und probieren können eben für
die zukunft dann auch weiterungen oder
erweiterungen
passieren eben weil die eben auch
erfahrungen mit uns oder mit den leuten
jetzt machen mit den tausend und
vielleicht sind es beim nächsten mal
2000 also ich hoffe halt einfach dass
wenn man daran teilnimmt dass ihm auch
für die zukunft sicher besser daran
vielen dank ja danke auch wir schalten
nachher nochmal zu dir dann möchte ich
nämlich gern von dem wir wissen wie das
jetzt eigentlich gelaufen ist was du
sagen würde ist ob das jetzt tatsächlich
ein konzept ist dass man auch skalieren
kann oder nicht deswegen lasse ich dich
noch mal kurz ein bisschen darum laufen
wir sprechen aber gleich nochmal weiter
aber wir sehen hier tatsächlich eine
ganz unterschiedliche umsetzung der
konzepte auf ganz unterschiedliche art
und weise wir haben mal was vorbereitet
und zwar eine grafik da könnt ihr euch
mal angucken wie das jetzt tatsächlich
am wochenende aussieht gibt es
verschiedene dfb-pokalspiele zum
beispiel hier in nürnberg das später
erster fc nürnberg gegen rb leipzig und
es gibt gar keine zuschauer so dunn
gehen weiter nach leverkusen da gibt es
eintracht norderstedt gegen bayer 04
da gibt es maximal 300 zuschauer wenn
wir dann in den norden einmal wandern
nach rostock da gibt es dann hansa gegen
vfb stuttgart von maximal 7500
zuschauern das war schon eine ganz
andere nummer und richtig kuschelig eng
gesetzt bei dynamo in dresden gegen den
hsv da sollen sogar ca 10.000 zuschauer
kommen also das ist ja schon wirklich
eine völlig andere nummer bund und
länder wollen jetzt auch in einer
arbeitsgruppe zusammen gemeinsam mal
gucken ob sie bundesweit geltende regeln
da sicher arbeiten können und darüber
möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit dem
virologen martin stürmer auch hier noch
mal gerne kommentare fragen zu dem
ganzen thema hier bei mir rein ich muss
aber jetzt schon mal das so auffordern
ein paar sachen zu lassen zum beispiel
behauptet es gebe keine pandemie
da würde ich sagen das sagen die
hinterbliebenen von mehreren
hunderttausend toten weltweit sind da
glaube ich anderer meinung herrscht
immer wenn wir jetzt aber mal das thema
beiseite lassen sondern uns dahin
orientieren was jetzt das bessere
konzept ist wir sehen irgendwie
fußballspiele mit gar keinen zuschauern
bis hin zu fußballspielen mit 10.000
zuschauern
welches konzept würden sie aus
biologischer sicht befürworten ja ich
glaube der kevin hat daraus ganz
sinnvoll ist gesagt er hat gesagt das
ist ja jetzt erst mal eine kleine menge
an zuschauern p hereinkommen und
vielleicht sind es beim nächsten mal
2000 man kann ein bisschen erfahrung
sammeln damit lernen ich glaube das ist
ein ganz vernünftiger ansatz wenn man
sich dann dafür entschieden hat mit fans
generell zu arbeiten und wieder wieder
dessen betrieb aufzunehmen dann finde
ich sollte man das kleinen schritten
machen sich das konzept sorgfältig
erarbeiten und eben auch mit einer
geringe menge erstmal testen
weil wenn es dafür nicht funktioniert da
wird das mit mehr auch nicht
funktionieren
aber wenn es jetzt gut läuft mit einer
geringen anzahl dann kann man sicherlich
anfangen ein bisschen zu steigern
aber wann können wir den wissen ob das
gut gelaufen ist oder nicht mehr
grundsätzlich kann man ja zum beispiel
sehen wie ist die situation bei der
anfahrt wie ist die situation beim ins
stadion eingehen bei der karten
kontrolle rund und sind da lange
schlangen habe ich irgendwo staus habe
ich eine situation wo menschen sehr sehr
lange auf engem raum zusammen stehen
auch wenn sie die maske tragen habe ich
andere probleme mit meinem konzept weiß
ich die toiletten sind überfüllt oder
ich krieg die leute nicht vernünftig aus
dem stadion wieder raus all das sind ja
fragestellung die wichtig sind
ich glaube das kleinste problem ist die
situation wenn die leute auf ihren
plätzen sitzen ich denke das drumherum
das ist das entscheidende und das kann
man mit einer kleinen gruppe an menschen
besser testen
einfach rein von der logistik her gut
aber eine kleine gruppe von menschen
sind ja nicht 10.000 fans in dresden da
gucken wir mal an da gibt es ja auch
bestimmte hygienemaßnahmen die dort
jetzt von dynamo durchgesetzt werden
müssen da haben wir auch mal kurz was
vorbereitet um das mal uns anzuschauen
da gibt es einmal klar die abstandsregel
die eingehalten werden muss das ist
natürlich hin zum stadion manchmal
schwierig und nasenschutz ist
verpflichtend und zwar immer nicht nur
wenn man durch darin jetzt man auch am
platz keine fans aus gebieten mit
höherem sieben tage schnitt das heißt in
dem fall mit 20 infizierten 400.000
einwohner es gibt keine gästefans und
alle müssen sich registrieren mit ihren
personendaten ist dass jetzt ein konzept
wo sie sagen würden hersteller okay das
könnte funktionieren wie wir sehen ja
hier sohn wieder spielern des
unterschiedlichen ausbruchsgeschehens in
der
einzelnen bundesländern jetzt ist im
osten der republik aber deutlich weniger
fälle auch flächendeckend als als im
rest der republik insofern kann man
natürlich da etwas ambitionierter sein
natürlich ist das mit 10.000 leuten
schon eine ziemlich große hausnummer und
es wird sich zeigen inwieweit das
tatsächlich logistisch umsetzbar sind
gespannt auf bilder wie ist jetzt
tatsächlich mit den fans aussieht ob er
wirklich die regel die sie davor geben
so in dem maße einhalten können sprich
das wirklich die abstände gewahrt
bleiben und die masken auf bleiben da
bin ich noch nicht so ganz überzeugt
dass das wirklich funktioniert hier ist
eine frage von andreas maria auf
facebook fakt ist selbst in den lokalen
halten sich die leute nicht an den
abstand und das ist ja tatsächlich auch
ein problem teilweise dann geht man zwar
schönes stadion hält sich da an die
regeln und alle machen braucht mit und
danach geht man einen trinken und dann
knuddelt man sich doch wieder in der bar
oder davor dann ist das ja alles wieder
hinüber oder ja das ist eine
grundsätzliche diskussion die wir die
wir in allen bereichen führen die frage
ist wie gehabt die diskussion auch bei
schulen zum beispiel geführt was macht
das sicherheitskonzept in den schulen
befehl sinn wenn die nach dem schule
außerhalb des schulchores sich um die
arme fallen das können wir grundsätzlich
nicht verhindert und nicht vermeiden
es ist natürlich jeder selbst
aufgefordert regeln konsequent zu
versuchen auch in seinem privatleben
einzuhalten sich eben mit seinen
kontakten zurückzuhalten abstand halten
macht getragen auch im privaten bereich
aber letztendlich wenn man solche
konzepte machen
dann endet dieses konzept hat eben
tatsächlich an der stadion tour oder am
schultor und dann geht es wieder in die
verantwortung des einzelnen
das ist eben tatsächlich schwierig da
gebe ich ihnen recht ja auch der frage
stellen und recht hier gibt es eine
meldung von auf youtube von dem kanal
wissenschafts videos meinte bremen hat
einen kindes mag für 6000 menschen
erlaubt ich denke das kann von region zu
region anders sein blödsinn meiner
meinung nach weil spanien fast identisch
sind
ist das tatsächlich so das geht ja so
ein bisschen in die richtung stadion
da verhält sich quasi die effekte das
infektionsgeschehen immer gleich und
dann ist es auch egal wie man aus macht
kann man das dann flächendeckend zu
beschließen
ja es ist es das spiel startet
vergleichen man muss sich immer
überlegen wie letzten
die zuschauer bewegung oder die besuchs
bewegung sind und auf einer kirmes ist
so so alte erfahrung ist ja so dass man
sich da doch sehr dicht gedrängt oft
durch schiebt und eine kirmes hat
natürlich auch viel kulinarisches dabei
und da sitzt stehen die leute
irgendeiner würstchenbude und da sind
die masken natürlich runter beim fußball
gehört in mainz da ist essen und
getränke nutzen mitnehmen es gibt kein
alkohol und das ist glaube ich auch eine
ganz ganz wichtige voraussetzung um
ebenso ein stadium betrieb durchzuführen
und das unterscheidet zum beispiel denn
auch die situation auf der kirmes war
ich glaube eine kirmes ohne die ganzen
futter boden und getränkebuden das ist
wahrscheinlich auch nicht gerne dafür
geht man ja dahin eine andere sache die
jetzt erst mal hier im chat auf deinen
kommentaren auch gesagt wurde es
ungerecht dass es in den in den stadien
unterschiedlich läuft das dann irgendwie
keiner gucken darf in dresden dürfen so
viele gucken aber es gibt noch andere
gefühlte ungerechtigkeiten weil es ja
noch mehr branchen gibt sie keine
zuschauer mehr haben die
veranstaltungsbranche zum beispiel und
das sehen auch tatsächlich fußballfans
teilweise kritisch wir haben heute abend
mit einem gesprochen der sich vorher bei
uns gemeldet hat er ist fußballfan hat
aber viele freunde in der
veranstaltungsbranche und der hat
folgendes gesagt also ich finds der
umfeld das andere branchen da stehen
gelassen werden als beispiel musik sport
events im kleineren rahmen
david halt wie gesagt keine zuschauer
zugelassen die events können ohne
zuschauer stattfinden
und ja beim fußball ist ja schön dass
irgendwo ein anfang gemacht wird aber
wenn dann sollte man versuchen allen
irgendwas zu ermöglichen so das ist
jetzt die frage hersteller kann man das
vergleichen also kann man open air
konzert was ja auch schon teilweise
durchgeführt wurde
roland kaiser dürfte auftreten mit einem
fußballspiel vergleichen und wie ist das
dann mit dem infektionsgeschehen in
geschlossenen arenen also in hallen oder
in konzerthallen werden ja ich denke
wenn das open air konzert ein ähnliches
konzept hat wie jetzt die spiele spricht
dass man darauf achtet die eingänge so
zu kontrollieren dass ich keine großen
staus bilden das die anzahl der
teilnehmer so beschränkt ist dass wir
vernünftig abstand halten können masken
getragen werden auf kulinarisches
verzichtet wird vielleicht auf eine
vorgruppe verzichtet wird um die
verweildauer auf der stadion so gering
wie möglich zu halten dann ist das
sicherlich ein argument das man auch mal
sagen kann vergleichbar mit dem fußball
macht man auch hier wieder konzerte
ich glaube dass auch problem werden die
geschlossene räume sein weil wir da
natürlich eine ganz andere situation
haben was eben die übertragung durch
ihre sohle an geht das eben doch die
wahrscheinlichkeit die gefahr der
erosion bildung deutlich höher ist als
draußen und dementsprechend ist eine
geschlossene halle noch mal eine ganz
andere baustelle und das erfordert viel
vorbereitung um einfach auch mal zu
erkennen wie hoch ist das risiko und wie
es die luftzirkulation in so einer halle
überhaupt wo sind risiken wo staut sich
dann vielleicht ebenso wolke kommt und
und also ich weiß eine räume sind
tatsächlich eine ganz andere nummer
da sind wir gespannt was bei diesen
versuchen rauskommt die jetzt gerade
durchgeführt wurden hier auf facebook
jetzt gerade viel länger bei jutta
tremel dies schreibt 10.000 zuschauer
geht es bei euch noch wahrscheinlich
nicht in einem restaurant stehen die
hälfte der plätze leer man nennt es
abstandsregel aber es geht ja um fußball
und nicht um ein restaurantbesitzer der
ums überleben kämpft ja das ist jetzt
tatsächlich eine große diskussion ob
hier mit zweierlei maß gemessen wird ob
manche branchen doch bisschen mehr
politischen druck ausüben können oder
dürfen und er gehört werden als andere
da hatten wir diese woche auch schon
einen stream mit der
veranstaltungsbranche aus berlin gibt es
noch einen kommentar und da müssen wir
vielleicht noch mal generell über die
pandemie reden herr stürmer klaus dinge
schreibt alles was in richtung
normalität geht ist in ordnung
es wird zeit dass das gefasel von der
gefährlichen pandemie endlich der
wirklichkeit weicht wie gefährlich ist
dann ist diese pandemie in ihren augen
mittlerweile immer noch genauso
gefährlich wie am anfang wir finden uns
in deutschland in der guten situation
weil man bei der pandemie
doch sehr große maßnahmen aber sehr
wirksame maßnahmen getroffen worden sind
um die ausbreitung des virus hier stark
zu reduzieren es ist uns auch nicht
gelungen sie ganz auf null zu reduzieren
aber wir haben es auch geschafft die
risikogruppen
sehr sehr gut zu schützen das gelingt
uns auch jetzt noch und dass die
pandemie ist nicht beendet sie ist im
prinzip noch genauso gefährlich wenn wir
jetzt nachlässig werden dann werden wir
auch wieder viel mehr menschen sehen die
infiziert sind und wir werden auch viel
mehr intensiv belegungen sehen
intensivbetten bewegung und auch mehr
tote deswegen ist vorsicht immer noch
das oberste gebot ja ich habe mal ganz
kurz google aufgerufen und nach chur
wird 19 toten weltweit geguckt leicht
hatten wir mal kurz auf meinem
bildschirm
da kann sich jeder informieren die
todeszahl fotos fallzahl wird derzeit
mit 910 1891 menschen angegeben ich
glaube da kann man nicht sagen dass das
nichts ist so herr stürmer vielen dank
für ihre antworten ich sehe gerade sonst
ich gucke noch mal kurz so wird noch
eine frage an sie sehe die sie
beantworten könnten aber das ist glaube
ich nicht der fall
aber ich glaube wir werden noch öfter
die gelegenheit haben miteinander zu
reden nicht bedanke mich gucken sie auch
gleich das spiel oder ein spielen dann
mal gucken
ich muss jetzt erstmal mit ein bisschen
meine familie kümmern die hat so ein
bisschen drunter gelitten unter dem
heutigen tag weil ich sehr viel
unterwegs war und dann schauen wir mal
ob er vielleicht noch ein bisschen
fußball gucken können dann machen sie
das wir gucken jetzt noch einmal zum
fußball in mainz meine kollegin nina
niebergall ist ja immer noch dort und
ich hatte sich ja gebeten einmal zu
schauen denn das konzept umgesetzt wird
was und sein fazit jetzt du bist ja
schon ein bisschen länger da ist das was
funktionieren kann und vielleicht auch
mit mehr als 1000 leuten ja genauso wir
stehen jetzt hier schon eine ganze weile
und es ist tatsächlich so dass die
zuschauer kommen in sehr großem
zeitlichen abständen hier an
normalerweise passen hier ins mainzer
stadion über 33.000 menschen wenn sich
jetzt natürlich 1000 menschen über eine
gewisse zeit verteilen hier langsam
ankommen dann funktioniert das ganz gut
dazu kommt die leute ziehen mit also die
allermeisten zumindest die ziehen sofort
ihre maske an wenn sie hier aufs gelände
kommen
die verhalten sich gesittet und wirken
auf der anderen seite aber auch so als
würden sie sich jetzt auf das spiel auch
freuen
gut dann sind aber gespannt was das
fazit dieses wochenendes wird nina
vielen dank dass du dich davor stadion
gestellt hast vielen dank euch im
livestream und für eure kommentare und
ich würde
wir sehen uns nächste woche wieder mit
neuen live streams zu neuen aktuellen
themen bis dahin macht in das wochenende
ich sag macht gut und